so i okay here's something about me
i'm a nice dude one of the nicest until
i'm not
you have a switch well yeah i think just
like everybody everybody is some
form of gray listen i used to have a
little anger issue on stage
there was a clip online i don't know if
it's still up there from the tower
theater in philadelphia
of me going in
on this person someone kept talking or
they were yeah going in
were they less me and more somebody else
who had just come on before me
yeah and they were just talking through
the whole but i used to have a tiny
little anger issue
on stage just because of other things
that were happening in my life and
you know for me stage is really the most
honest me
sure you're gonna like so when there's
bad things happening on
in my life you're talking about it yeah
andy you're gonna see it so i don't know
if it's still up there
but it was me just going some of my fans
used to call that guy angry josh
oh damn yeah because see angry no no no
no
but angry josh look i grew up with three
older brothers
again i'm cool until i'm not let me ask
this probably takes a lot for you to get
to angry josh
does you know the big thing is is
somebody who i feel like has a complete
disregard
for other people or somebody who feels
like they live by a different set of
rules so let me ask your opinion on this
and i may have gone too far i also i'm
not the kind of guy that you want to
start a prank war with yes
because you know you start at hey let's
scare him and i end with his
[ __ ] on his face when he's sleeping
let's have him suck my dick yeah
i don't know that that's a prank i just
tied your shoes together now i'm sucking
it
so uh all right so
this dude i'm walking my dog now i am
recently this is
a two days oh [ __ ] i am
this is where i land on masks everybody
i'm not a doctor
so and i'm respectful of other people so
my thing is like look i'm not a doctor
and i generally play things safer than
not safe
so until everybody knows everything
about it
i err on the side of safety sure no
matter what right but if i'm i'm out
walking my dog it's 6 45 in the morning
outdoor in my residential neighborhood
with nobody on the street
i'll have my mask in my hand just in
case i pass by somebody or somebody's
wearing a mask and i'm respectful and i
put mine on
okay but if i'm by myself and there's
nobody and we're outdoors
i'm i'm not even if you're around people
outdoors you probably shouldn't have a
mask on but i'll wear just so people
shut the [ __ ] up
so yeah let me guess you're walking your
dogs okay you said put on a mask so
check this out i'm walking from across
the street other side of the street
guy without a mask on
gets into his car window down and
here's what i'm not okay with man i
don't like passive aggressive [ __ ]
i really hate i don't i don't like you
being an [ __ ] to my face but at least
i know who you are
yeah and so window down so he knows i
can hear him
goes [ __ ] [ __ ] put on a mask
and i go hey man i'm
i'm standing right here yeah i go you
don't have a mask
he goes i'm in my car [ __ ] but i go
yeah but you're screaming out the window
like you're putting as much out there as
i am because i'm not walking up and down
put on a [ __ ] mask and i was like hey
dude you say your awards in the mail
i said hey there's no reason to be
screaming at me man we're neighbors yeah
i get we're tense
and i was just trying to diffuse it see
how the shape yes there you go
and his dog that's how anybody out of
shape or older it's like put on a
[ __ ] mess my dog
barked at him right and he goes and you
shut that
[ __ ] dog up too wow and i go hey dude
i go this is and i said something back
to him
and he goes [ __ ] you i better not see
you around here again right
so i want to ask you remember i told you
i'm not the type of dude
to start these games with tell me if i
went too far did you [ __ ] on his lawn
i last night my dog took [ __ ] i picked
it up in the bag he's gonna hear this
you know this right yeah he picked it up
in the bag i hope he does
and in [ __ ] i wrote be kind on his rear
view
on his back window type move how do you
now where do you
where do you fall on that disturbed too
far ah no
i'd rather you do that than get a
physical that's not my thing man because
it's not my thing
i'm not going to physically i don't i
don't want those problems also
you don't get to be an [ __ ] with
computers did you have a i did it i did
it with the plastic bag that i picked
the [ __ ] up with i would
throw up just put my finger on the [ __ ]
so i couldn't do either
listen man but for me like i'm not do
you want to know
okay this is where i'm at when you when
people play jokes with me
that i just don't know where the line is
when i was in college
i had a friend of mine this dude i
worked out with who scared me coming out
of my bathroom once
and i was like and he goes oh [ __ ]
got you man prankster you're never gonna
get me
prankster and i go okay so and he
dude would do he went as far as when i
would go to his dorm room
he would before i walked in he would
grab his toothbrush and his hairbrush
and put him in places where he could see
right i go i got to use your bathroom
man i use your bathroom
he's like sure i go out i got to take a
dump you all right he goes yeah
so i didn't have to get dump i had
grabbed his workout hat
and um i jerked off in it
and so the next day when i saw him
working out he had sweat
he had sweat just rolled rolling down
his face
so me and my friend knew who'd known
what i did
we were just laughing the whole we made
sure we did extra cardio
my man my man was just so we let him do
it for two days
but like yeah i just i'm not gonna play
those games i'm not that guy
i'm not that guy man i don't play any of
those games oh i do but you but you and
your older brother beat the [ __ ] out of
each other
yeah so we played jokes on each other
yeah that makes sense yeah but like as
far as confrontation goes i mean it
would have i mean you'd have to hit my
kid or my girl
but i would never never never you're
talking about lawyers especially
these [ __ ] in california no one's
actually get like
when we're in like the thicker cove and
i was riding without a mascot on my bike
going 30 miles an hour
and these two dummies on horses like
wear a mask you [ __ ] idiot we're in
the middle of nowhere
yeah and i get off my bike and start
arguing again i'm like well your horse
doesn't have a mask
and it's just you know they're like well
we'll see you here tomorrow i'm like
okay
i was there tomorrow and i was like i
mean there's no cameras around so
who's starting to fight with you dude
that is [ __ ] from like
the palisades that's this girl was hot
so i gave him a pass
what are we gonna do dude yeah like you
realize i'm gonna twist your
[ __ ] neck up there's no k there's no
there's nobody here no one around
just out of curiosity say something i
would call you how big is that dude how
big is he all right let's say 200 pounds
shredded you like he's in shape okay it
doesn't matter
i would call you say josh would i'll
film it for you what do you want me to
do this guy oh piledriver
sure and what should i do to the horse
like what do you want me to do with this
horse man i think you hey josh you want
a horse dude i think you pile drive him
and then you put his girl on your horse
and you ride off
that'd be sick later dude she's like no
it'll
move miles down the road well i mean
it's so weird though man
it's so hostile i can't imagine that
i'm with you man like in order to get me
in a physical confrontation at this
point
i'll get heated but i'll argue with you
i i mean i like a good argument yeah me
too you know
there was a guy i the closest i came to
physical was actually
two weeks ago when somebody called beth
a [ __ ] dang for not wearing a mask
no we're walking you know we have those
slow streets in our neighborhood
you know like the city of l.a has put up
like giant cones and stuff and they turn
some streets in the neighborhood into
slow streets
because gyms are closed so you can walk
your kids and ride your bikes
and you're not supposed to ride your
drive your cars up and down the slow
streets oh you can't drive your cars
if you you have to live on that street
dude it's super cool there's a couple in
my neighborhood there it is
so you can it's for people who want to
ride their bike or walk with their kids
and get outside right low slow streets
garcia not just slow streets
right so it's it's fine it's kind of
cool and this dude came
zipping down the street and bet and cool
when he turned
he uh and you're allowed to walk in the
middle street that's a deal he almost
hit somebody and beth was like slow down
[ __ ]
and he screeched and he backed up and he
said what'd you say
[ __ ] and i was like damn it yeah
because
if you insult my girl now i can't have
it that's you know what i mean i was
like
damn it again still not going to
physically hurt him but pee on them yeah
i piss on it but
damn it like by the way also the reverse
how many times in the world do you think
a woman has said something to a bouncer
or to another dude and a guy has been
like no [ __ ] no
dude now i gotta i know i gotta get in
there now nightmare dude yeah
but but he uh he backed it up and he got
out of the car man
he got out of the car got out of that
car and what'd you do well i had my dog
in my dog
is a deterrent your dog's pretty
gangster man i've seen that he was a
durant because my dog's super chill when
the guy came out and started pointing
his finger and my dog was like
hey is this is it go time the dog's like
is this happening is this
is this is this how we're doing is this
still simulation or am i down to
[ __ ] this dude up yo he got
real real quick and i didn't know if he
was gonna but the guy
you know what else man and what i found
out about myself
because this dude got out of the car
super tight tank top
short shorts and this is interesting
so i'm not a hateful dude i'm not racist
i'm not homophobic i'm not misogynistic
i feel like i'm pretty good with
everybody i'm even keel i want people to
live
love have a good time but you know when
he came out and called beth a [ __ ]
do you know my first instinct the f word
yeah and and
not because you know it's going to hurt
that's it i know that's it you know what
i found
i walked away and i told beth i go you i
almost did you drop the fbi no i said i
almost called that guy
something he didn't want me to call him
and well you want to hurt him
it has nothing to do with how i feel no
it's all about what can i say in this
moment that's going to hurt
you the moment do you dwell on like when
you ride away are you going through the
fight in your mind
you know what i did for a second and i
was like i feel like i
actually i didn't escalate it best thing
didn't escalated because i don't think
about it like when
i have a confrontation whatever it is
fight with my girl fight with those
stupid horse people someone yells at me
bikers
all the time yeah you all the time i
don't even i don't give it
any energy as soon it's just the way my
brain works like right now it's like
throwing interception
right next really i don't even i don't
know
the next day someone's like hey that
dude yelled yesterday i'm like i don't
think so
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this front of a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song